afganistán celebra su primer ramadán
bajo el gobierno islámico desde la toma
del poder talibán el pasado agosto para
millones de afganos la tradicional
celebración musulmana será diferente
especialmente para las mujeres que
sufren con más fuerza el yugo talibán
para fotos o letras 3d que alejan de la
es la diferencia entre este ramadán y el
de años anteriores es que ahora hay un
gobierno islámico la gente es musulmana
estamos en tierra musulmana y por estas
razones nos sentimos muy bien todos los
musulmanes se sienten bien porque viven
bajo el sistema islámico y el gobierno
islámico
está siendo llevó es estar también la
escasez de alimentos y el colapso
económico marca en el mes sagrado
musulmán en el país dado que los fondos
internacionales que recibían fueron
suspendidos con la llegada de los
fundamentalistas ahora debajo de su
dolor los precios se han disparado y la
situación económica de la gente es débil
en afganistán la gente ha venido al
mercado a comprar artículos de primera
necesidad pero los precios son muy altos
muchas personas que han venido regresan
a sus hogares con las manos vacías
en los que millones sobreviven del
diario y lamentan no poder celebrar los
rituales tradicionales
se acerca el ramadán y no tenemos nada
que comer durante este mes es difícil
ayunar comiendo solo pan mis hijos están
enfermos y no tengo suficiente dinero
para comprarles medicinas a
los miembros del grupo talibán pasarán
por primera vez un ramadán con todas las
comodidades
el ramadán anterior no fue como este
ramadán para nosotros experimentamos el
ramadán en las montañas y en los
desiertos con muchos problemas y no
teníamos acceso a estas instalaciones
desde a todo en las plazas y mercados de
kabul se sentía el bullicio de las
últimas compras para la celebración del
iftar o la ruptura del ayuno con la
puesta de sol